hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft top-5 irgendwas und zwar
habe ich mir gedacht ich stelle euch
heute meiner meinung nach ansicht nach
die top fünf besten skins in minecraft
vor dazu muss ich sagen dass das
größtenteils kind sind die von youtube
an wirklich genutzt werden ich glaube es
ist sogar nur 1 kinder bei denen es noch
nicht in dem video gab aber das ist
eigentlich relativ egal weil das ganze
jahr meiner ansicht nach das heißt
natürlich mein eigenes kinderball wenn
mein eigenes kind wenn der mir nicht
gefallen würde dann wäre da ja auch
nicht wer das nicht meins kinder nicht
in den top 5 und gefangen einfach an mit
dem fünften platz
der fünfte platz ist nämlich schon mein
eigenes kind ich wollte mein eigens ding
jetzt nicht eigentlich auf die platz auf
platz 1 setzen weil ich finde auch gar
nicht mehr dass erst so geil ist ich
finde ich natürlich cool und benutzt ihn
natürlich auch weiterhin durch möchten
jetzt umgehend ändern deswegen habe ich
ihn einfach mal auf platz 5 geschoben
jetzt natürlich immer so die sache warum
findest du dieses kindern geil warum ist
der platz fünf ja ich finde diesen skin
extrem cool weil ganz einfach das ist so
eine mischung aus diesem sky also aus
diesem agenten detektiv ich glaub
detektiv ist oder von team fortress 2
zusammen in minecraft halt zusammen
gepixelt dann ganz normal mit schuhen
mit diesem ganz normalen sachen die des
bayern hat einfach in pixel form ganz
normales gesicht vom spann und expertin
in tf2 ja immer so eine maske auf und in
minecraft ist dass man einfach diese
villiger maske von sum manager deswegen
passt das ganz gut weil ich selber halt
auch jetzt und minecraft und ich mag
villiger und das ist halt einfach mal
platz nummer fünf
platz nummer vier ist nun anders gehen
und zwar finde ich dieses kind extrem
cool da ich habe einfach gesucht nach
pokémon skins bei pokémon ist meine
absolute lieblingsstadt wird nie zu alt
für pokémon ich hab mir letztes mal die
komplette erste staffel angeschaut und
habe wirklich damals aus der schule raus
wo genau angeguckt und direkt
eingeschaltet und pikachu jedenfalls
muss ich sagen dass man da dieser samen
und schicke halt meine 3 l
links pokemon sinn zusammen mit che box
noch und mit lokal rio aber dass du gar
nicht zur sache jedenfalls hab ich dann
einfach geschaut ok wovon gibt's denn
von diesen lieblings pokémon familien
bestens kenne da habe ich diesen shulman
das kind gefunden bzw den blumen das
gehen den findet ihr unten auch in der
beschreibung falls ihr euch den mal
selber anschauen wollt beziehungsweise
downloaden volt und das ganze ist ganz
cool gepixelt also wirklich auch mit
seiner flamme am rücken und alles
mögliche und deswegen ist das bei mir
platz vier und jetzt kommen wir zu platz
nummer drei der wieder von einem
youtuber blick wird platz nummer 30
die zombie von slammer eventuell in
einigen animationen von euch erkannt
der tritt in fast jeder animation von
slammer creations ich weiß gar nicht
genau was er tritt auf jeden fall nahezu
immer auf ist ein ganz normaler zombies
kind mit einem helm noch an und mit
blutigen hemd und ein bisschen anders
gepixelt und finde ich auch extrem cool
einfach weil das ganze auch mit shader
und wenn man das ganze eventuell von der
kontur ein bisschen höher stellen würde
bzw von der ehrlichkeit wird das ganze
auch extrem cool aussehen deswegen finde
ich diesen dave die zombies geht es bei
mir platz nummer 3 von slade operations
und jetzt mal weiter mit platz nummer
zwei und ich sehe schon kommen ist das
video heute extrem kurz wird aber manche
denken ja auch immer so auf das video
von vier minuten oder fünf minuten
gedauert er hat saß daran bestimmt auch
nur fünf minuten
diese top fünf videos daran wird sich
erstmal meisten weiter recherchieren
muss und schneiden und blabla blog wir
machen weiter
platz nummer zwei ist regenzeit mit aids
also zumindest heißt des kindes ich habe
einfach gedacht so voll wie das kinder
habe ich damals den übelsten lacht
vielleicht bekommen auch immer wenn ich
so ein behindertes kind auf dem server
sehe muss ich immer noch schmunzeln und
zwar ist es ganz einfach so ein ganz
simpler skin eigentlich mit mit so ein
typ mit anzug und krawatte und alles
mögliche allerdings seine fresse hat
halt einfach so verdrehte augen eher
sabbat der bund ist extrem groß und
seine augen über die jahre hinweg weil
die so als maske dargestellt werden mehr
oder weniger in dem skin und man rede
jedenfalls ist das bei platz weil das
einfach so komplett abgefuckt das kind
kommen wir auch nur zu platz nummer eins
insgesamt ich habe ich vom platz hat hat
den skin habe ich meine ich schon mal
irgendwann gesagt dass das mein
lieblingsgegner sogar schon mal
vorgestellt oder schon mal
was damit gemacht jedenfalls ist der
monkey skin von blue monkey also diese
affen ceasar blauer affe mit krawatte
und alles mögliche finde ich extrem cool
ich habe gedacht selber meinen eigenen
kindern auch mal so ein bisschen zu
modifizieren dass ich einfach so eine
villiger nehme und die krawatte anziehen
und dann komplett nackt oder so aber da
bin ich noch am plan mit skins und
sollen dass es auch gar nicht so wichtig
ist und gar nicht so ausschlaggebend
irgendwie vom eine videosequenz genau
aussehe doch ein gewisser weise
eigentlich schon ich habe als neues
profilbild und wenn ich das dann ändern
würde dann wird nicht nur guten
ebenfalls dass man platz nummer eins der
blue monkeys kinn von blue monkey finde
ich extrem cool diesen affen ist richtig
mit viel liebe zum detail und alles
mögliche und ja ich würde sagen das
war's dann auch schon mit dem top 5
skins video wenn ihr weitere ideen habt
ihr irgendwelche top fünf folgen also
das ganze ist der serie hat natürlich
irgendwann ende weil ich kann nicht zu
allen sachen in minecraft top fünf
machen ich könnte natürlich müssen
dritten ziehen die top 5
glöckl minecraft oder sowas aber das
möchte ich nicht vorstellen welche
cooleren ideen an schreibt es mir bitte
und in die kommentare irgendwie sowas
wie stell doch mal deine top-5 blablabla
vorgehen da echt langsam die ideen aus
ich hatte ja schon technisch könnte noch
die top fünf richtigen shader forscher
ich habe bisher nur creepy shaders
vorgestellt aber egal wenn ihr weitere
ideen habt schreibt nun in die
kommentare bitte bewertet das video mit
einem daumen hoch falls euch gefallen
hat schreibt mir euren lieblings kindern
die kommentare die download in der
beschreibung und dann sehen wir uns
übereinander wieder das ist mein finger
new york i